I guess actually
um people now want to be famous for no
reason everyone wants to be famous and
you don't need resources to actually be
famous these days you just need phone
and good Network and then boom that's it
like Tick Tock is free YouTube is free
Instagram is free people will just make
any they would just watch movies and
make any script in their head and
discuss just go for it and that's how
they will end up to be famous even if
it's to gain sympathy or pity or just to
be even if they're not true so why
wouldn't they take it as an advantage to
themselves which is wrong to the person
who would be falsely accused but it
would be good for them because they will
gain they will even gain money Fame
everything they want so why not you know
yeah so it's a it's like a good tool in
their hands to take advantage of